players who you know just uh follow what
other players do but jordan's more of a
creator he's more of a unique thinker he
comes out with ideas and that's why he's
been part of magnus's world
championships team so yeah let's see
what he's got here is we see the queen's
gambit declined
and uh yeah the queen's camera declined
black not taking the baits we do see
um one of the most trendy variations of
this system uh the tarash variation of
the queen's camera declined
and okay what will magnus play here
brings out his bishop this opening has
been very popular uh by
team magnus players that means magnus
cast himself daniel dubov jordan van
furies people that magnus has worked
together with
in world championship training camps and
okay we see maybe a rarer line not the
most uh common over the last few turns
but the kind of whole nature of the
position revolves around black's pawn in
the middle of the board which is an
isolated pawn if that's a strength then
black is doing great if it's a weakness
a target for white then magnus will be
happy
but who do you think this position will
favor in terms of style i mean i'd say
white uh in general it depends if black
can get any activity but um it is it's
really about the center of the board and
that pawn the isolated pawn and uh
magnus loves
slowly maneuvering around a slight
weakness and i would have fought here
magnus would be comfortable in this
position yeah i think so too magnus
slightly frowning just to show you
mentioned a couple of captures there
simon um and he's going for it
real attention already um if the queen
doesn't go and take this pawn if you
remove the knight from the board then
suddenly this bishop is under attack and
uh white's just a clip on up no no no no
no no no no no you can't do that not
against not against anyone yeah i mean
these are too ugly these isolated forms
here
gives me the shivers
why did jordan think he spent nearly a
minute on that move um and normally
jordan he's the type of guy yes he's got
full uh he's full of opening ideas but
if he knows an idea he'll play it
instantly
he doesn't want to sit around and bluff
and kind of play mind games maybe a
personal thing which is a bit of a
mistake but um i think you're probably
right and he has he has
there's absolutely no trouble and i i
think this is maybe the correct kind of
continuation after capturing the night
and uh here we go it's getting very
short it's getting sharp crazy stuff on
the board
yeah i mean this i mean white
i don't know both
white castling me this looks so logical
and uh
you know who's who's king is weaker now
black's king surely black's king's in
the center white's king is safely tucked
away i don't like this of black just
just instinctively it just looks
like something wrong for black here yeah
i mean unless you can somehow trade the
queens off where black maybe we'll be
fine
i think magnus is going to win a
miniature i just have a feeling he's
going to win quite a quick game here
so just
instinctively this looks horrible for
black i mean white's got everything you
want surely and i expect the queen will
move there now
so if the queen moves three squares uh
it can even swing to the other side of
the board it attacks the knight so but
what was magnus doing yeah i'm sorry
about talking about what is that you
know keep the queens on the board i mean
the the general rule is if your king is
safer than your opponent's king white's
king is safe from the black king keep
the queens on the board i mean this
can't be a bad move but it is safety
first right yes definitely not a bad
move we should clarify so we can't be
too critical
magnus still has the advantage if queens
come off for example okay magnus
frowning there but uh if black's queen
takes the white queen then one of the
white rooks will recapture and white
gains time we're going to see it happen
on the board white's rook now will
attack the black bishop in front of it
black's knight as well a bit unstable
we're going to see a lot of trades and
magnus is going to grind away in the end
game maybe magnus will even win one pawn
in the process so he's chosen a safety
first approach as you mentioned simon
but
why win one pawn when you can go for
checkmate and
wow
well we have to go back to the board
because we were kind of talking about
the king
the bishop
defending retreating but we never
thought about the king and look at
magnus's face he's just i mean a moment
ago he was just frowning
i don't understand i i mean i vaguely
saw this but i just assumed dwight was
winning a piece what is jordan's idea
after this capture black simply has to
take back this night now with his pawn
now white is going to give a check
um with his rook the black king is going
to get forced away from the defense of
his bishop i think he's got a sneaky
idea in mind of double attacking a
couple of things later but uh to defend
the bishop and the thing is if the pawn
attacks a rook sorry david
the thing is if there's a check the
bishop can actually block and run away
to safety so this is completely fine for
white white has an extra bishop and as
simon mentions the pawn can step forward
attacking the white rook but i guess you
just move out there away you just take
this pawn and after your bishop falls
you just push create a safe square for
your king and uh you're just a pawn up
with white and
more to come
yeah because usually because kya said
there are some openings where the black
black pieces are in the lead
maybe there might be
this is on the tour
this is all the tour oh
we'll start revealing all of it tomorrow
friendships maybe french defense yeah
and uh meanwhile one of the decisions
that i mentioned
as well as keeping white's rook on the
fifth rank which looked risk-free
completely winning for white uh instead
magnus has given up his rook for the
black knight and now he's retreated his
bishop to this square which guards the
first rank so black's rook cannot come
down to the first rank to check the
white king because the white bishop
guards any infiltration
so right now it's a bishop and knight
against a rook now and slowly but surely
you'll
you win the game i i would have thought
um i think it's quite key as well on
that line you show simon uh sorry just
for example okay he jumped in with the
knight first same right yeah okay so uh
if the bishop had jumped it's nice that
you can actually take this bish take
this pawn and you can still come back
and block
any potential checkmating ideas we
normally say give your king some
breathing space because you don't want
to get checked checkmated on the back
rank but the bishop can block magnus
though he doesn't want to go passive
with his bishop for example
he doesn't want to risk for example the
black rook coming and grabbing this lone
pawn so he goes the other way but same
idea you mentioned there simon and
very effective the white knight just
completely blocks the advance of black's
only hope the past pawn
first is free so at some point you
should be able to create a past pawn at
some point that passport will probably
become a queen so it's kind of looks
pretty simple his winning plan to be
honest i mean uh long term i i don't
think there's anything even
you know that black can do because
you're stopping all black's counter
playing yeah black's pawns are fractured
and uh i mean these pawns are these
pawns are isolated and uh knights are
fantastic against isolated pawns and
your plan in action simon just rerouting
the white king one more square and the
black rook will never break into the
white camp um it's important that the
black rook if it does come in it can be
completely neutralized by the white
bishop stepping back defense defending
sorry this one
in the corner but also attacking this
weak black pawn with players like jordan
it's much harder he's very creative and
sometimes that can be you know
dazzling brilliancy but on other days if
it's not quite 100
it can be disastrous because he's always
trying to do something creative he's
always trying to think outside the box
and it's harder to play that way in the
long run so it's a lot of energy it's a
lot it's just the energy isn't it
because rather than just copying doing
things you're used to you're always
thinking of something unique
and yeah that just makes you know it's
harder to keep that tempo up yeah if
someone did that you'd be like okay
i resigned i resigned yeah you are
inevitable try that next time david yeah
doesn't work out so well for him the
second time he says oh
let's spoil this
yeah big marvel fan literally the
highlight of my song is going to be
watching the new thor movie
so um yeah
meanwhile
yeah the mighty thor but uh this
position not looking so mighty for
jordan i'm looking forward to the new
top gun movie i think that's out soon
welcome to the
what is it
danger zone no i know it's not it's
something else
welcome to my way to the dangerous
highway that's where he went
i just freestyled my lyrics all right i
just i'm not i just make him up you know
call her that way
you take a look at them and you're like
you see
i think it ages very well so definitely
and uh talking of 80s 90s these two
players born in the 90s there
i mean it's only only going to be one
winner and that is magnus carlsen the
position has not improved at all for
black and look at those white pawns
they've started to push
um literally nothing for jordan to do i
wouldn't be surprised if he just gives
up hope soon and yeah there's simply
nothing to do here for jordan look at
the clock times as well how imbalanced
is that
more than 10 minutes for magnus in a
easily winning position at this point
the white king can just continue
centralizing itself or even marching
towards the right side of the board
white's bishop knight have everything
locked down but you've lost control a
little bit now because the black pawn is
suddenly free
the white knight was controlling that
one but now
you know you don't want to allow any
counter play this is just key stop the
counter play don't put your pieces on
bad squares uh like this night even if
you can win a pawn in the process and
there's no stopping that white king from
getting to its destination as well
because yes you can attack pawns but hey
the knight can actually step back to the
c4 square or
magnus just goes well i don't even need
to defend it that king is just gonna run
to chase and gobble up those pawns on
the right yeah so white giving up this
pawn in the center to the black crook
but instead just going after these pawns
i think magnus one of the best patches
of his career in uh early 2019 he was
just every time on the white side of the
queen's camera declined he would just
smash his opponents off the board um
just it was just a joy to watch we
rarely talk about like which openings is
magnus the expert one he's the universal
player but uh this is the opening he is
the expert in
one of them
he's so good at everything i mean this
is you know openings and you know adapt
them into his own play and yeah it's
it's just one of his big strengths yeah
opening books he's just pouring over
them all the time i mean this game is
not going to last much longer now white
is simply going to capture this black
pawn on the right side of the board
white's two pawns are unstoppable and at
the very least white can give up one of
his pieces the white or the white bishop
for black's pawn in the middle of the
board those two white pawns uh sorry on
this side they're just gonna match up
and win the game i mean you'd never got
back in the game simply he never
recovered
um
maybe a slight opening disaster from
jordan but magnus's technique ever since
that one small slip in the opening
just been
just been
flawless
and now the white knight jumping just
attack the black rook but also to stop
black's pawn from marching forward that
white knight will keep the black pawn
under lock and key and white's pawns win
the game
and i'm looking at the bar on the bottom
of the screen mishra mamadiaro mama
yarov is
still world number five something like
that the bar all the way over to
mishra's side and we do have a result in
this game it is a win for magnus carlsen
the second win in a row horrible start
for jordan today he uh only has one
point out of those four for his games